how did you decide that right now was
the right time to make your first trip
to the border
well it's not my first trip i've been to
the border many times
i said back in march i was going to come
to the border so this is not a new plan
it only took 93 days but kamala harris
finally visited the border
kind of the vp snapping at our own peter
ducey there
and claims that seeing the situation
firsthand was always the plan
even though she repeatedly laughed off
questions about going and
republicans have been pressuring harris
to visit for months
now instead of touring the epicenter of
this crisis
she was hundreds of miles away from
where the most serious problems are
and harris didn't bother to offer up
solutions to stop the surge of migrants
coming across
instead she pointed a finger at the last
administration
and focused on her favorite phrase root
causes
while insisting everything is totally
under control
as you know we inherited a tough
situation but we have seen extreme
progress over these last few months
this issue cannot be reduced to a
political issue
we're talking about children we're
talking about families we're talking
about
suffering and our approach has to be
thoughtful and effective i am committed
to ensuring that we engage in an active
way
on the root causes the focus that we
have placed on the root causes
invest in the root causes and democratic
congressman of veronica escobar who is
traveling with the vp
today getting a lot of attention for
saying this
welcome to el paso welcome to my
community
to the new ellis island to the capital
of the border
i am standing before you with a heart
full of gratitude
uh madam vice president thank you for
being here
so martha you covered a lot of this this
afternoon what
jumped out at you today well that
comment jumps out at me
i mean that is not ellis island ellis
island doesn't work where you've got a
big hole in the fence and people
like you know just make their way
through ellis island is a process
you have you know back then you had to
go through it there's still a process
now
um to become an american citizen and a
lot of people go through it and do it
the right way
um i also thought it was strange that
congresswoman escobar said you know this
is where we greet
americans as they come across the border
you know this is a dangerous journey
and when i listen to the vice president
talk about how
we have to be so concerned about these
children and we have to care about them
and you know that they were in that they
inherited this disaster i i just can't
help but think
about these children that get dropped
over the fence by themselves
after being left by coyotes and they're
screaming in the night holding their
teddy bear
um asking someone to help them i'm not
sure how this is a more humane system
than what we had before
granted there were you know legitimate
questions about what was done before
but i'm not sure how this has become you
know where all the progress is and how
this is going so much better
uh at this point remains to be seen
katie she didn't actually go to the
border she went to the airport
and then she went to a border patrol
station that wasn't actually on the
border and then a processing
facility it's almost like she's
insulting our intelligence isn't it the
rule that
if your place doesn't count that you've
been to unless you actually leave the
airport
right so she went to the border patrol
facility didn't go to the actual border
well there's a wall there so maybe they
didn't want the optics of
the vice president standing in front of
the border wall that was replaced by the
trump administration
i'm calling this the nothing to see here
tour because they don't want to go to
mcallen because then they would see
all of what's actually happening she
claims that this is about children and
people and humanity well it'd be nice if
you went to visit them and talk with
them and maybe listen to some of the
stories about their journey and how they
got here and
what the root causes are of why they
decided to make that journey talk to
those people
firsthand and the other thing that was
so interesting about the comment made by
the congresswoman is she says it's the
new ellis island
ellis island was a welcoming place for
people who wanted to become american
citizens well didn't
the vice president just go to guatemala
and say don't come
yeah so she's undermining the
administration's whole point of don't
come so when they say that there's been
progress
are they talking about if their goal is
allowing as many people as possible into
the country
without any kind of system well that
goal is being reached
every single month in record numbers but
if the goal is to somehow stop the flow
or actually find out what's going on
she's not meeting with the people who
are making the journey to find out why
they
left in the first place so she says that
there's been progress jessica there has
not been progress
don't disagree i don't have the effort
today
there is just no progress why would she
lie like that
i really wouldn't call it lying i
understand it's friday though so
in that spirit i think we can just have
an adult conversation about what goes on
at the border under every administration
everyone has this problem
right decades-old problem i'm not saying
that the numbers aren't spiking right
now katie
i heard the little gesture i'm taking
account of it
i did think that it was a missed
opportunity
to not have someone like congresswoman
cuellar who
is actually a border who is also a con a
representative of a board of a border
state but in a
higher influx of migrant area let's say
with her who has called it out and said
i don't need a photo op
we need actual help here and aoc and a
number of the other
representatives have visited the
facility said these migrant facilities
for kids are unacceptable
i don't think that those kinds of things
and showing some compassion and talking
to kids talking to parents who've made
this journey
makes you look worse or makes your
policies look worse because
every administration struggles with this
and unless you're super polarized
like the people on really the far left
or the far right about it i think people
understand how complicated this issue
is and would be amenable to listening
about what the solutions are and just
what you heard from people what their
journey was like
the humanity side i feel like she
doesn't want to go to that facility in
mccallum
or the rio grande valley because she
doesn't want images of her
of course in that situation that can be
used against her in a democrat primary
the squad will kill her
with those pictures she owns that she's
a part of this administration
doesn't want to be associated with it so
she dodged it and went to el paxo
west texas 800 miles away greg you've
been wanting to talk about this
all afternoon i will give you the last
word i
was i i was up all night thinking about
this stuff well you know what ellis
island is what they really believe
that's what you just saw the slip
showing it shows the gulf between what
they want america to believe and what
they really believe
which is why when people say all the
both parties are struggling with this
the reason why both parties are
struggling in it is because one party
really doesn't believe uh that the
border needs to be that strong
right that they don't believe it if if
they did they would have at least
told people not to come and would have
kept the wall there which was the only
very new variable that we had in this
debate since i've been on this planet
that was the
that's the first time i've ever seen an
actual change in the debate
which caused everybody to hate it she
seems very defensive
doesn't she yeah she reminds me of me
when my wife goes through the amex build
you know and she keeps citing she cites
root causes more than a tree surgeon
which she should be really deciding root
solutions
and there are solutions i just mentioned
one but they can't
they can't seek practical solutions if
they were somehow linked
to either trump or the republican party
so instead
she treats it like a chore she's like a
she's like
when your parents make you take a young
sibling to the movies
that's what she acts like when she went
to the border she really didn't want to
be there
she didn't want to be there and she
feels like she has to be there because
she's being made to go there
and she's so defensive about it it
really is interesting that she's
supposed to be the successor for 2024.
right now there has to be some buyer's
remorse yeah she seems uncomfortable
with the mantle of the vice president
she didn't want to go she didn't want to
go
it's a thanksgiving i think it's just
very obvious
english no interesting solving listen to
how she's being talked about
constantly she's doing this for george
bush 41.
what has she done because she's got the
white house for
name one thing you can't you can't you
can't do it
i can't do it i can't do it jessica and
it's friday give me more time i'm just
glad we had an adult conversation yeah
unlike all those other days yes thank
you for bringing so much maturity to the
table
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else